this is all our conflict
it's pretty devastating we're all very
very shaken who knows what she witnessed
in the past month
[Music]
we're always in the Philippines on the
southern island of Mindanao is a
provincial capital
now Philippines of the nation is largely
Christian but Mindanao itself the island
has a as the biggest concentration of
Muslims and Philippines it's a small
city sits on a lake very very poor area
lots and lots of guns among the
population and long history of
separatist conflict this was what looked
like it might be a new front in that
fight against Islamic state you saw
Islamic state appealing to their
followers that if you can't get to Iraq
or Syria go to the Philippines and this
was where in May 2017 hundreds of
militants had taken control what they've
done they've taken the city by storm
it happened very suddenly it certainly
caught Thirteen's government forces by
surprise because it wasn't very much
reporting coming out of it it was really
difficult to get a sense of it from afar
we knew going into this that there was
going to be nowhere that we could
definitely say was safe it was difficult
to know exactly where the different
positions were because the government
forces didn't want media embedding with
them so you were very much just on your
own in the city but as soon as we got
there it was apparent that this was
really full-scale urban conflict
I remember us crouching down in a roof
I'm just kind of looking at each other
because it was constant gunfire
SolidFire fights going on left right and
center across the city and mu thinking
wow this is full you know
the first day is always the worst
because you've no idea what you're gonna
get so you're literally filming
everything that moves
you expose their character and take a
step right
you just never know when you're gonna
record something that is valuable and
you're never going to get that chance to
get it again we're pretty close to the
front lines here the fighting is intense
and it is sustained it has been going on
like this know for several hours it's
quite difficult to film a moving
aircraft against a bright let's Skype
it's quite difficult to get in focus to
get the exposure I they were using
fighter jet so using helicopters try to
get those in a few occasions you get
them dropping bombs and it's you know
people in the buildings were you know
getting smashed
I realized fairly quickly that they were
doing so much bombing had plenty of
opportunities to get the shots it was
just constant
that's the irony of it you're worried
that it's not going to be the story that
you thought you'd pitch to London and
then we got there and we thought well
actually this is this is much much
bigger than we were expecting this is a
strong story that needs to be told here
we had a brand new drone which I hadn't
used before this was its first outing
I was quite cautious to begin with
staying at a relatively safe distance
I remember my producer asking me if we
could get a little bit closer so I took
a brave feel and went in and got
properly low
I remember sweeping shot across the
mosque and it looked amazing there were
fires everywhere and there was ash
floating through the air
[Music]
there are also white specks that were
moving so quickly you know fractions of
a second so I assumed was white pop it's
let basically flying from the screen
some of them were towards the driver is
been known to use drones in Iraq and
Syria so the military is shooting them
down the military were using their own
drones as well and so is were shooting
them down it was constantly people were
trying to stop us film
what we did see it was pretty
devastating
we've got a lot of footage of very heavy
fighting but what we really wanted to do
was speak to some people we'd heard
about the horrors of people you being
used as human shields sex slaves we kind
of wanted to hear that directly for
ourselves rather than secondhand
well order are you guys gonna go in yeah
we thought that we were going to an area
that was relatively safe so I'm running
to the far side of this street or a
diagonal yeah okay so guys joining each
other straight down to the blue because
of not being entirely sure whose sights
we might be in at any one time when we
went to cross the road we would go one
after the other in single file right
let's go
knocked on the door and it wasn't
opening and so as we were waiting
suddenly in came a huge round and it
sounded so close
take the door and burst in within a few
seconds and we then inside targeted they
didn't seem random
it didn't seem by accident I wasn't a
stray bullet I felt targeted every day
being the sniper felt safe but then
seemed turned out there was a fire or
some sort very nearby which was filling
the building with smoke there somewhere
never an OK at that point I won the
option was to get back out get to our
vehicle and get away ok
I was positioned to go first so it's
quite a moment running out of the door
and into the street not knowing what was
gonna happen thinking maybe there's
gonna be another shot
we had to run around the vehicle jump in
wait for the whole team to get in get
that sliding door across and then get
out of there that was terrifying really
running back out that door into an area
is potentially someone looking down the
scope of a rifle watching you do that
that was frightening it was just a
desire to get into that that vehicle as
quickly as possible and get out of there
I think we're all very very shaken but
thankfully we managed to get everyone
out safely
we would then heard they were going to
have a few hours ceasefire we are in the
street waiting for teams of civilian
rescuers who were going to try and go
into the militant control site to try
and bring some of the hostages out
because it was apparent that there were
so hundreds and hundreds of people
trapped over there
after a number of hours of waiting two
army vehicles came out from the militant
controlled area
remember the jeep stopping and just
seeing in the back of it a female
soldier holding a very small baby
he looked extremely confused
there was this little face this little
girl's face and she just looked bemused
who knows what she witnessed in the past
month behind her two very young women
maybe in their late teens who just
looked just so confused so dazed who had
been living through by that point a
month of airstrikes in the militant
controlled area of actually sheltering
in a basement the image of the people
coming out of the army vehicle and
trying to process what had happened he's
really quite stark and there were
hundreds and hundreds of people in that
situation
liberation basically look like terror
station the difference between the
aerial shots from before where it was
green and you could see trees and after
five months of fighting it's just all
gray this cement dust everywhere it was
just such a different place daily air
strikes had leveled huge parts of the
city this was not lost on the government
forces side of it was an issue of
people's perception that regardless of
who had started this the government
forces had done this
[Music]
the most difficult thing about getting
into the city once it had been liberated
was getting the permission from the
military to go in it was still very
dangerous there
there was ids potentially breakdown
houses there was walls that could come
down so we were in the military's hands
in terms of getting in they had to trust
us we had to trust them and they were
also keen not for us to show too much of
the damage because a lot of that damage
was due to military bombing they were
very concerned that this might shift
quite quickly from anger with the
militants to anger with the government
once we're in though it was something
else really we'd seen the city from afar
when we first went and now we were right
in the middle of what we'd been filming
from above and the drone and through a
long lens camera it's quite surreal to
me be there and just to see what litter
was left there was graffiti all over the
walls claiming that Islamic state
caliphate
there was people's possessions sprawled
out across the floor there was just
utter devastation really
[Music]
just talking to the survivors and who
the people that have been pulled out
these people have not only lived through
that but their houses their livelihoods
everything has been destroyed
pretty much and it's just it's quite
emotional talking to these people the
house is totally destroyed it's just
horrendous you know listening to the
stories of what they went for it no no
this is only the lift look what happened
here place world help us we are what
really jumped out was as they came out
they're shocked how much had been looted
from their own homes they everything
even irony even rice cooker small one
there was this kind of bubbling anger
from these people of who did this and it
was very clear that they blame the
military who do you think ticket
this place is controlled by a military
[Music]
as we left it felt very much that
there's this huge job in morale of not
only rebuilding the city which basically
has to start from the ground up they
have to completely replan that town but
also they have to win back the trust of
people who live there in what is a very
kind of fertile area already for
extremists
[Music]
the real test of morale was whether the
Islamic state could operate somewhere
outside of the Middle East
is this the start of what they wanted to
call the Caliphate in the region they
were pushed out but it took five months
to do it and during that time it was
powerful propaganda
this shows the chance to go and fight a
war with a National Army which is an
ally of the United States and hold them
off so there is a real danger that this
happens again this is not a one-off
[Music]